please welcome malin ackerman kat
dennings aisha tyler and
chelsea peretti oh wow
wow i'm so excited to be speaking with
you guys
i love women i love funny
and you're all so beautiful it's
beautiful funny talented women who are
gonna bring
what is a potent combination which is
holidays and comedy it
certainly is and i think it's something
we need right now
i used to spend christmas by myself
and now ironically i have a huge family
and it's completely different
but i really would be alone on christmas
but
thanksgiving was something i always did
with a big group of friends
and i love this movie i'm
freaking out i think it's going to be a
huge hit
it just looks so amazing i mean
malin you produced this yeah i did
it was actually my friend nicole peone
who wrote and directed it
um and she came to me with this idea and
she just said you know i think
let's put together all the craziness
that has ensued over the years
and i thought this is a great way to to
start producing
first of all um miss dennings when i
used to be friends with a woman named
lorene
well i'm still friends with her but when
i was first getting to know laureen
scafaria
she had written nick and nora which is i
thought one of the best scripts i had
read
and i was already a huge fan of yours
but
you're so mesmerizing and so beautiful
and then i heard you actually posted
something about me which made me so
happy because i was like i'm
on a borderline restraining order
towards you and
maybe you won't call the police which is
exciting
um i would never call the police on you
drew barrymore
i um yeah thanks for saying you think
i'm cool i don't even know how to
process that
um uh you are cool and everyone here is
cool
um yeah laureen's amazing um that was
kind
you know that was one of my first you
know
starring things and i was
just so happy to be on a set we shot in
new york
and this was amazing we also shot this
all in one location which is something
new for me um
the film does look amazing the budget
was pretty small and
the one trailer or two trailers we had
were like down at the bottom of a hill
so none of us even bothered going to
them
um but that's the sign of a happy set
yes aisha you know i love
seeing you in an ensemble comedy what do
you love
about doing comedy with multiple people
it's such a it's such an art form to
know
when to lean in when to let someone else
go
i love that balance in comedy with a
group of people
yeah i mean you know i come out of
stand-up which is uh
you know a deeply you know individual
and kind of in a lot of ways lonely
discipline
but i love comedy so i'm the kind of
comedian who would then sit in the back
of the room and laugh at everybody
else's jokes and
people used to say they knew they were
bombing if only i was laughing because
i'm like a really supportive laughter
so i'd just be in the background like
yay go you and be like oh that joke is
terrible i've got to throw it out
you know this movie we just got to we we
it was a great script
and it was it had a lot of heart and the
comedy was kind of icing on the cake of
this
uh experience and we just were
ping-ponging all the time and laughing
and i
like that's the delight of creating is
when everybody around you is really
engaged
everybody wants not just to be funny but
for you to be funny
and chelsea you were like you had a baby
while you were
making this film i did i still have him
[Laughter]
he's still kicking around somewhere but
uh
yeah this was uh i my nanny
god bless her would come and drive up to
the house we were shooting in and then i
would run down and
nurse him and then run back up and
it worked out i mean when
you're doing a comedy and you're
balancing
a baby how do you do it because i tried
and it was really really hard yeah i
should clarify when i say
nurse him i was putting on a nurse
uniform and just doing it
i was just doing weird no uh
i don't know how you balance it all it's
uh you just feel
constantly well i guess you just like
never have a pedicure anymore
in a lot of ways i'm an american hero
it's it's absolutely true if we don't do
this then the human race does
not go on so i think you are a hero and
every woman who
you know decides to have children is an
absolute hero to keep us all here
but i do think and i are keeping people
alive in other ways yes population
tequila shots and comments
also advance the you know the state of
the human existence yes
oh i never want this to end
[Music]